dr marty mccary is at johns hopkins
university of public health he joins us
tonight doctor thanks so much for coming
on it'd be interesting to kind of take
the politics out of it roe v way out of
it whether it should be legal or not out
of it just to the science of it we know
that children in utero fetuses whatever
you call the developing human being in
utero feels pain correct
that's right tucker somewhere between 15
and 20 weeks babies will actually resist
the instruments of abortion now row is
based on viability but viability has
been changing babies survive now at
approximately the halfway point of
pregnancy at 21 and 22 weeks
babies have survived outside the womb so
ironically we sometimes do fetal surgery
on a baby inside the womb of the mother
to save the baby's life and yet at the
same age in other settings surgical
instruments are used to abort a baby
so there's a great irony and now
you can barely talk about it i witnessed
it as a medical student i'll tell you it
doesn't matter which side you protest on
around this issue if you see the actual
images of what's happening and a baby
resisting an abortion it'll weigh on
your conscience but today you can barely
talk about it nurses can get fired if
they don't participate students are
ridiculed most of the professional
medical associations have taken a
political stand now supporting abortion
right up until the third trimester
it's beyond belief and it does nothing
to restore confidence in the medical
profession no offense to physicians like
yourself but it it it doesn't i must say
dr marty mccary appreciate your coming
on again thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight